hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast three decades of HIV detection
presented by duck professor Mark van
rinse I am seen fan of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
lab routes is the leading scientific
social networking site and we're proud
to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information please
visit us at lab roots comm here's how
the presentation will work we want to
hear from you questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen we'll try to get to everyone
but if not we'll make sure to follow up
with you by email you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you cannot hear
receive this presentation properly let
us know by clicking on the support
button at the top right or the Q&A
button in the lower left today's webinar
is sponsored by Abbott Abbott is
committed to helping live the best
possible life through the power of
Health for more than 125 years Abbott
has brought new products and
technologies to the world in nutrition
Diagnostics medical devices and branded
generic pharmaceuticals that create more
possibilities for more people at all
stages of life Abbott is a global leader
in in vitro diagnostic offering a broad
portfolio spanning immunity clinical
chemistry hematology blood screening
molecular identification point of care
and informatics for more information
please visit a pet calm I would like to
now introduce today's speaker professor
mark van Rijn perfer professor and rinse
graduated as a medical doctor from the
University of Leuven in 1919 he then
worked at the department of microbiology
and immunology at Albert Einstein
College of Medicine in New York and
received his PhD degree in urology in
1994 since 1999 he is a professor at the
University of Leuven in Belgium
currently he is associate chief of the
Department of Laboratory Medicine and
hence led clinical virology laboratory
at the University Hospital illusion in
belgium has published over 270
scientific papers in peer-reviewed and
MEDLINE indexed journals
you read chapters two six books on viral
molecular evolution and bioinformatics
professor fan rants teachers virology
epidemiology and biome addicts at the
University of Leuven in Belgium I will
now turn it over to preserve and restore
his presentation thank you very much and
today we'll talk about three decades of
HIV detection we know that HIV has been
around much longer but it has been
already 30 years that we are able to
detect HIV this is my disclosure so this
is an abode sponsored talk and let's
start with going through time and if we
do so we have to start around 1900
around the end of the nineteenth century
beginning of the 20th century many
European countries and also Belgium had
colonies in Africa pongo was at that
time the mostly personal property of the
Belgian King Leopold - at that moment
the beginning automotive industry needed
a lot of rubber - to make tires and
Leopold - he used actually forced labour
to extract rubber from the the forest
the equatorial forest in fact he was an
indulgent we don't recognize that enough
he was an extremely brutal dictator
killed about 10 millions mutilated many
millions more is the production quota of
rubber were not met due to demand for
rubber and all MO and always more and
more rubber core to escape the the
atrocities in Congo hundreds of
thousands of people fled into an often
unfamiliar jungle where they encountered
chimpanzee which they normally would not
really meet all that often and that's
the the common chimpanzee which you see
here that's the plant tropical deities
and the pygmy chimpanzee the de pan
paniscus and they lives in the area in
red in in the north of Congo and the
neighboring countries to the north of it
now we have to realize that human and
chimpanzees share 96
some say 98% of their of their
ene so they're extremely genetically
related and that also means that we
shared the possibility to be infected by
by similar infectious organisms and and
this is what really happened this is how
the simian immunodeficiency virus jumped
species to two units now how does this
how did this happen
let me sexually transmitted diseases
between chimpanzees and humans that's
not going to happen mean that that
that's that's near impossible
however they eat bush meat and bush meat
killing of great apes such as
chimpanzees together with deforestation
or in fact the greatest threat to
survival of these chimps so people are
eating chimp so now when these chains
are well cooked that's not necessarily a
problem however when the the meat is not
thoroughly cooked then the viruses in
the chimp species can pin jump to to
humans and this in fact has happened a
number of times here you see in this
phylogenetic tree depicting the
phylogenetic relationships of HIV you
can see that HIV mmm on separate
occasions jumped from chimpanzees to
humans probably around 1900 or or so
this was from chimpanzees HIV one
subtype all did not originate from
chimpanzees that originated from
gorillas so eating a bush meat-eating
chimpanzees led to the zoonotic
transmission of a simian
immunodeficiency virus r2 to humans net
was really the the beginning of the
beginning of HIV this was then carried
by by people who got infected arm
traveling along the streams rivers the
congo stream to to léopoldville to what
is now known as Kinshasa where it is
thought based on file static analysis
that the the epidemic are reached the
the big city they're already in the in
the 1920s completely
unrecognized but it started spreading
from from there and then really in the
1950s 60s and 70s the infection made its
way to to Europe to the Caribbean from
there to the u.s. to Australia and
ultimately the rest of the world and
they're now um about now the virus is
present in in all all places and the
home planet and I really DHI v story
starts in 1981 1981 was the year that
the first IBM personal computer was
launched also the space shuttle Columbia
was launched in 1981 Ronald Reagan took
office on January 10 1981 shot on Mars
Turkey and this was also the year when
pope john paul ii was well there was an
assassination attempt on the 13th of May
this was also the year that to doctors
at San Francisco General Hospital dr.
Cohen dr. Valle birthing suddenly saw
patients with an extremely rare disease
Kaposi sarcoma which it is East which
they normally would not see to disease
which is in fact caused by human herpes
virus type 8
it's an opportunistic infection which
they saw in homosexual men and this
disease was until that time so rare that
when they saw even a couple of cases
they knew that something new and
something rare was was going on this was
also the year of 1981 when in UCLA in
Los Angeles Michael Gottlieb so also
patients with another rare disease with
Pneumocystis Carini which is a yeast
like fungus and he saw a couple of these
patients in his practice and in the
practice of a Pollock of hinge or
Wiseman a physician with largely gay
practice they also sought this this
Pneumocystis fungus in in these patients
and immediately they knew that this was
something which seemed to be present and
maybe in even growing
numbers in the indicate population the
first description in the literature of
what we now know as as HIV was in
morbidity and mortality weekly report
which is an obscure journal only read by
epidemiologists I guess which describes
weird outbreaks in in different parts of
the world although it is really focused
on the on the United States definitely
at that period so in in June 1981 they
described the Pneumocystis pneumonia
epidemic in Los Angeles and that was
really the beginning of the realization
that that there was a deadly epidemic in
in first in people who were gay the CDC
in July 1981 try to reassure the
population by saying that and I quote
here there is no apparent danger from
contagion to non homosexuals the best
evidence against contagion is that no
cases have been reported to date outside
the homosexual community or in women so
in the beginning they thought well this
is a disease which is only in
homosexuals and and in the beginning the
CDC was not overly worried about this
this disease the first name of this
disease was politically extremely
incorrect and in fact it was great gay
related immune deficiency a term which
was quickly forgotten
but that pointed really to the to the
fact that in the beginning they told
that this was only a disease in gays
that was 1982 that was the year when
Erno Rubik had his Rubik's Cube launched
the year of the first CD player the year
of the Falkland war and the the movie
which was extremely popular in 1982 was
et and that was also the year that we
realized that in that HIV was
transmitted using intravenous drug use
so it was not only in the gay community
also intravenous drug users would would
have it and this was also the year
that we have the first idea that HIV
might also be transmitted through blood
transfusions and people who receive
blood transfusions in that period for
example in the United States had about a
1% chance of contracting HIV and
especially hemophiliacs who need factor
aid from many many donors became
infected with HIV but not only with HIV
also with very often hepatitis C so this
led to an extremely weird situation
where at that time they knew that there
was something in the the blood supply
but at that time they could not test for
it so they knew that the disease existed
but they have no assays for for it yet
1982 was also the year when the Centers
for Disease Control coined the name
eight for the for the first time in fact
that was on July 27 1982 the acquired
immune deficiency syndrome was now
replacing great as the official name for
this for this disease mind you that by
the end of 1982 President Reagan had not
mentioned the word AIDS in public yet it
was at that time not on the not only
political agenda at all 1983 was the
year when the first version of Microsoft
Word was on North computers this was the
year when George Romney her J who is the
cartoonist who brought us Tintin
died this was the year when Lake Walesa
received a Nobel Prize the Polish
union-leader received a Nobel Prize
piece Nobel Prize and this was also the
year when Sally Ride became the first
American woman in in space on the
Challenger mission this was also the
year when the virus was first discovered
the AIDS virus and this was by Luc
montagnier French biologist who isolated
a what they knew was a dealing for
tropic retrovirus from people with with
with AIDS and they called it the lymph
adenopathy
associated virus or L a V the qualta a
received the the Nobel Prize in medicine
in 2008 together with Harold for housing
for his work on human papillomaviruses
so he received a Nobel price for it this
is Luc montagnier in his younger days
showing for the first time in 1983
electron micrographs of HIV particles
budding from the the surface of an
infected infected cell this was also the
year that we learned that HIV was an
enveloped virus so we got to know
something about the structure of the
viral particle this was also the year
when the first electron micrographs were
made where you can see here in red the
HIV particles budding from an infected T
helper cell in 1983 it was also
discovered and this was a big surprise
that HIV was also present in Central
Africa and was in fact killing scores of
people there this was realized in 1983
it was published in 1984 in The Lancet
by the Belgian beta field who for the
first time had a study that strongly
argued that the situation in central
Africa represented a new epidemiological
setting for this worldwide disease that
of significant transmission in a large
heterosexual population so since 1983 84
we realised that HIV is not only a
homosexual or infant intravenous drug
user disease but is also driving in the
heterosexual population and this is
really when dd8
hysteria started suddenly everybody was
becoming afraid of HIV the the wild 60s
ended in in 1983 and people became
really afraid that they they would
contract HIV 1984 was the year when the
first Apple Macintosh computer was used
with the first graphical interface the
first Mouse was the year when Purple
Rain was the the popular song by Prince
the year of the famine in Ethiopia
leading to almost a million deaths and
this was also the boy
of Russia of the Olympic Games in in Los
Angeles this was the year when Bob Gallo
sort of rediscovered the HIV virus
himself actually almost completely
ignoring the work of Luc montagnier and
he gave it a different name he had
already discovered HL htlv-1 and too so
for him it was very logical to call his
virus the htlv three and that was the
name in the literature that many of the
Americans are used for that
so human kenan photopic virus 5/3
however we now know that this was
probably actually he sort of
rediscovered the the same virus from a
sample which he received from rick
montagnier and although look montagnier
disagreed with it he did not receive or
did not have a share in the Nobel price
that that would contain a received at
this point in time people became
extremely anxious because HIV was a
disease where you cannot spot which
person carries the the AIDS virus people
would look completely healthy and still
harbored the virus and and you could get
infected through these people only to
concern Aparecida
where we're all confronted with with
AIDS even Superman could get AIDS and
this was the time when the the
advertisements for the the anti-aids
campaigns really started to be very
creative at that point in time it was
not only important to explain what is
HIV how can you get it but also how you
would not get it from for example a bug
bite for some people it was quite
surprising that you could not get HIV or
AIDS from a mosquito that would bite you
even if it had bitten a person with HIV
a couple of minutes earlier
you wouldn't get AIDS in a restaurant
where people would suddenly be afraid
that their waiter with in the kitchen
bleed on their salad and people would
really be
become a little bit paranoid about about
getting getting HIV and this led to in
fact create discrimination of AIDS
patients where people would not touch a
person's who were infected with with HIV
people would think that they would get
it from using kitchen utensils from
touching doorknobs that were touched by
HIV patients from going to the same
toilet for drinking from the same cloth
a lot of awareness was was really not
there on on how to catch HIV and how how
not 1985 was the year of we are the
world part of life eight against the
hunger in Africa it was the year when
Gorbachev introduced love most
perestroika when the the Rainbow Warrior
was bombed by the by the French secret
agents because they were protesting
nuclear testing this was also the year
when Rock Hudson died from AIDS and and
that was a wake-up call this was the
first time when a famous American died
of AIDS and this was also the first time
that in September 1985 so more than four
years after Ronald Reagan took office
that he first pronounced the word AIDS
in public and that was not even in a
speech that was in response to a
reporter's question so in fact he
managed for four years not to pronounce
the word AIDS in public that changed in
1985 and to his credit after that he
mentioned it quite a lot but the first
couple of years this was not especially
on the Republican agenda and it was
largely ignored but that changed after
1985 1985 was also the year when the
nucleotide sequence of the AIDS virus
was was published so from then on we
know exactly the genetic composition of
the of the d8 virus and luckily this was
also the year when the first HIV
antibody test was was launched on March
4 1995 in see the smiling faces of
the avid broth arm launching their their
first HIV essay and I would that was not
a small feat I mean that was that was in
all the newspapers it was extremely
important that four years after knowing
that this disease existed there was now
finally a first generation of tests that
could detect theologically the people
having come in contact with the the HIV
virus so that was that was really a big
deal but it was only the first
generation of HIV in the u.s. is in fact
what was used I've antigens was a fairly
crude h97 lysate with HIV that was used
as as an antigen which meant that the
although the sensitivity was not bad
sensitivity was 99 percent the
specificity left a lot to be desired was
only 95 to 98 percent and all the IgG
could be could be detected so that was
the the first generation where they
really suffered from many false
positives and also from batch to batch
variation two years later there was a
second generation of HIV in universities
where they use not crude licensed but
recombinant HIV antigens and that
increased the specificity dramatically
to over 99% so now we had a sensitivity
of 99.5 and the specificity of over 99%
so since then the the HIV assays are
actually quite quite well it didn't stop
there a third generation HIV muna assays
were where they used mantich and
conjugates so that not only itg but also
other immunoglobulins would be detected
increase the specificity to 99.5 and
since then HIV assays can be rightfully
called the the rolls-royce's in serology
we know very much that that many of the
theological assays that we that we
use in viral aaja collaboratory are are
not reaching these numbers but HIV
assays luckily they they do and I
finally a little bit later in 1997 there
was the the four generation HIV
immunoassays that combined antibody
antigen detection so that sensitivity
even increased to ninety nine point
eight percent and the further we are
with the generations of amino acids the
smaller the window period really became
for these essays and I had a tremendous
impact what you see here is from a paper
in transfusion in two thousand really
reflecting the situation in the US where
pre testing the risk of and first look
at HIV there the risk of contracting HIV
after a transfusion was about one in a
hundred
um after 1985 that gradually went down
and mind you the vertical axis is
logarithmically there it went down and
down and nowadays except for maybe the
window period these things are an
extremely small window period the chance
of the risk of transmission of the
transfusion is in the order of one in a
million
donations and I'm dropping this was the
same for hepatitis C addresses meant
lower risk of transmission because of
the extremely high risk of transmission
of hepatitis B and that probably has
something to do with extremely high
fiber loads that are that are around
that has never went or the the risk of
transmission for hepatitis B never went
down
as far as we as we enjoyed for HIV and
and hepatitis C but these tests really
changed the whole picture of HIV
diagnosis now we come to 1986
I would beer that the space shuttle
Challenger exploded after 73 seconds of
flight killing all seven aboard that was
the year of the smoking ban on public
transportation in the US and later on in
other countries it was the the year of
the Chernobyl this
after and the year when out of Africa
with Meryl Streep and Robert Redford
wins the Oscar that was also the year
when the word HIV was chosen by the
ICTV the international committee on
taxonomy of viruses - well the new name
because people were arguing about la vie
about htlv 3 it was the the French
against the Americans and this was
settled by calling it a third by a third
name and that was the name that that
we're using now human immunodeficiency
virus HIV and that's a short name which
really stuck and was used very very
often this was also the year that an HIV
- was diagnosed in AIDS patients in West
Africa this virus also has a origin in a
monkeys this time in in [ __ ] mangabeys
there the reservoir for HIV - and we
know that the genomes of hiv-1 and hiv-2
are not completely identical but in
their genetic makeup fairly similar we
know that HIV - is causing a disease
which is less progressive which is less
fatal than HIV HIV one and is really
present in West Africa it started in in
around 1940 when the species jump in
probing in a b-cell happened between the
[ __ ] mangabeys and and humans then
during the the Civil War in in Guinea
Bissau
it probably propagated itself much more
dramatically in the 1963 1974 period and
and is now well you can find it
worldwide that the focus of infection
still is in in West Africa then comes
1987 with Black Monday on the 19 of
October with losses on the stock markets
of about 23% is with the beginning of
the Simpsons this was the year that the
world population reached 5 billion were
now over 7 billion and this was the year
when prozac was introduced
this was also the year when a lot of
campaigning was done and often by famous
people and here you see Princess Diana
to really show the world that touching
people with HIV is not a problem and the
fact that this was on the cover of Life
magazine sort of shows you that this was
important to do this was important to
show the scenes now more than 20 years
later quite self-evident but at that
time I can assure you it wasn't and and
these small gestures by by famous people
were were extremely extremely necessary
this was also the year that President
Reagan and Jacques Chirac who just had
took taken office met each other in the
US to talk about in Montana a Gallo
dispute and in fact they they announced
that well both researchers would share
the credit for the discovery of the AIDS
virus and more importantly that's really
why they met that the two countries
friends in the US would share the the
patent rights weakened federal patent
rights for the for the blood testing
this was also the year that Western
blots were becoming more and more used
in laboratories for confirmation testing
for HIV so at that point in time you
first had a theological essay 1 or 2 so
logical acid that would be positive and
then the another essay Western blot
essay would be would be performed to to
really nail the diagnosis a little bit
later this was which recombinant line in
you know essays which were a lot easier
to to interpret and here you see the in
olia from a no Genetics Belgian company
that is doing that quite quite nicely
this was also the year when the first
empty viral was was launched this was
zidovudine retro vir AVP was the the
first empty retro viral one of the first
antiviral medications that that came on
the market and the first one for for HIV
it the the patent was filed in in 1985
and a little bit later it was
it was approved and it could prolong the
life of HIV patients however it wasn't
really all that successful when you look
at the therapy success of mono therapy
with this one medication you could see
that you get a point seven log drop in
the in the viral load
but then after using this for a couple
of months resistance with developed and
actually the viral load would go up
again to to actually the original level
so there was only a very moderate
prolongation of the life of the of the
HIV patients
let me come to 1988 that was the year
that crack cocaine entered the streets
of the US and Europe that was the year
that George Bush who wins the election
against Michael Dukakis the year that
Salman Rushdie's wrote The Satanic
Verses and this was also the year that
on the first of December it was World
AIDS Day that was the first time that
this in 1988 was was celebrated this was
also the year that Abbott launched the
first automated benchtop Union chemistry
analyzer the IMF's
I remember it rather fondly because it
automated a lot of the the processes and
that was the machine that we run the
first automated HIV essays on all sewing
in my lab this was also the year that
DNA detection or I should say RNA
detection of HIV became became possible
by using PCR and quantitative PCR
methods it was and that was really quite
quite dramatic because the sensitivity
of an HIV detection went up dramatically
by at least six orders of magnitude and
it had direct clinical implications so I
mean now we wouldn't dream of doing this
anymore and everything is automated and
a lot easier but at that time seeing
these bands on electrophoresis was was
quite something because
the sensitivity was at that time
absolutely unheard of 1999 was the year
that the Hubble Space Telescope was
launched that Saddam Hussein invaded
Kuwait and start that with the start of
the first Gulf War with Operation Desert
Shield it would be Aaron Nelson Mandela
was freed from its Robben Island prison
and it was also a year that the ozone
layer became popular this was also the
year that Heath Herring died Keith
Haring the the famous American artist
and also social activist he only reached
31 years of age and he was really one of
the first eight campaigners making many
of the long-lasting visuals for the 48
campaigns 1990 was also the year when we
realized exactly how important fiber
load measurements became so at that
point in time viral load measurement
however crude we're becoming possible
and immediately it was realized that the
in blue you see the the drop in cd4
lymphocyte counts in red you see the
initial extremely high viral load and
then a gradual increase of the viral
load ultimately leading to depth this
was also the year that we realized that
if we really want to prolong the lives
of HIV patients we have to decrease the
viral load the lower the viral load the
slower the progression of the disease
and that realization led to an increase
in the efforts to make very good
antivirals this was also the year when
the the avid global HIV surveillance
program was was first successful really
looking at HIV strains from a glowstick
across the the planet to ensure that the
the assays that were on the market or
the assets that were developed would
pick up all the different of different
HIV assays are the different HIV strains
and in 1990 a very important one group
Oh
was was in this way discovered 1991 was
the end of the Soviet Union will also be
end of Freddie Mercury the elite singer
from from Queen who died from AIDS at 45
years of age this was the year when the
airbag was first installed in cars and
it was also the year of the major
cholera outbreak in in South America
this was also the year when the the red
ribbon for HIV was launched actually it
was first worn by Jeremy Irons
here with Julie Andrews at the at the
Tony Awards in June 1991 and since then
that symbol has become quite iconic this
was also the year in November 1991 when
the LA Lakers basketball star Irvin or
Magic Johnson are pronounced to the
world that well that he had HIV that he
had contracted the virus that causes
AIDS at that point in time D it was
still perceived as being a death
sentence and this was almost the same as
proclaiming his own death sentence but
it generated a lot of attention for the
HIV cause if a good guy such as Magic
Johnson would come out and say hey I
have HIV and and this is something that
that people in my in my close familiar
family circle should not be concerned
about in terms of transmission that had
an extreme impact 1994 was the year of
the first genetically modified tomato
I've had the premiere of friends it was
the opening of the Eurotunnel under the
canal in between school and Great
Britain was also the year of the
genocide in Rwanda where 800,000 Tutsis
were killed by the Hutus this was also
the year when H was the major killer of
American men between 25 and 44 here's
all the different reasons why people
died and the only
curve that crosses all these lines since
1981 it's eight and it reached its its
pinnacle in fact in term
of mortality in 1994-1995 and then soon
after started started declining this was
also the year when a lot of other
antiviral medications DDI DD cd40 we're
coming on the market and then people
could start using double nucleotide
combinations and I had a bigger success
than mono therapy in the viral load went
down 1.5 lakhs
and although resistance would still
develop the viral load would creep up
again but the first time it would not
reach the original level anymore and
there would be a sort of a net gain
after the after therapy so there from
that time on that was really a vegetable
interest to get as many people as
possible um on antiviral drugs then we
come in 1995 with the the liquid
epidemic of Ebola the year of the OJ
Simpson trial to quit local J Simpson
this was the year when the Schengen
Accord allow the free movement of goods
and people in in the first seven
countries in Europe and this was also
the beginning of the world wide web with
and we all remember that the first
browsers out of Hispania who allowed the
world wide net this was also the year
when the the Abbott action one of my
favorite machines was was launched where
one year later the the first HIV one and
two Eliza was was launched on this
automated platform this was also the
year when baited Piaf became the
president of UNH a position he held from
1995 to 2008 really putting a major
effort in curtailing the the HIV
epidemic
let me come to 1996 the year of Dolly
the first cloning of a sheep from an
adult cell the start of eBay start with
Spice Girls and the English Patient was
the major movie there that was the year
when we realized that the entry process
for HIV was not as easy as as originally
thought it was not a
a simple process this was the year that
we discovered that there were coal
receptors such as ccr5 that were needed
in order for HIV to enter to enter the
t4 helper cell when the ccr5 especially
the mutation the deletion of 32
nucleotides in ccr5 was discovered this
was also the year that we understood why
some people and this is Sarah Shyama who
is the prostitute in the in Nairobi in
Kenya why some of these women are even
though they probably encountered HIV
daily were not affected I mean they
survived for many many years because
they had a homozygous defect in the ccr5
HIV one co-receptor um this is present
in about petals as I've explained about
20% of the European populations quite
rare in Africa and maybe part of the
reason why the epidemic was able to
spread much more there but that was also
realized and so when you have a mutation
in ccr5 a deletion of 32 nucleotides 32
is not dividable by 3 which means that
you create a frame shift and the ccr5
Delta 32 gene product would not be able
to function at the core receptor for HIV
so if you are homozygous for that
mutation that means that your de facto
are uninfected all while using in normal
terms with with HIV 1997 was the start
of the h5n1 bird flu in Hong Kong it was
the start of Google it was the year that
Princess Diana died in a car accident in
the end of August and five days later
mother Teresa died in in Calcutta
this was also the year when the
advertisements for Mt AIDS campaigns
became more and more graphic in here
well the three sided eights of course
that was not true but now I have your
attention
stop it and people are using ever more
graphical pictures and representations
to to illustrate their their age
campaigns really leading to a situation
where people got sick and tired of these
campaigns and this was the year when
when many of the campaigns sort of went
down in intensity often being
accompanied by an increase in HIV even
in developed countries here you can see
this baby has the the chin of
grandfather the eyes of the father and
HIV from from the mother and they're
much more graphical representations or
much more graphical advertisements that
that I cannot show you here 1998 was the
year that Pfizer launched viagra that
Monica Lewinsky had his affair or had
her affair with Bill Clinton it was the
year of Titanic host of the year that
Osama bin Laden attacked the American
embassies in Nairobi and in Dar es
Salaam this was also the year that the
determined I say the the point-of-care
assay or the assay that you could do at
home was was launched with in fact for
these rapid assays a very decent
sensitivity and specificity but that was
launched in 1998 this was also the year
when the genotyping are looking for
genotypic resistance to HIV became ever
more popular so that people who wear an
antiviral therapy would be tested
regularly general typically to look for
drug resistance mutations in the HIV
population in their blood if resistance
was creeping up then some of the drugs
in the cocktail which these patients
received would would be changed so that
they become susceptible again 1998 was
the year when highly active
antiretroviral therapy or heart was
introduced using a triple combination of
three different drugs and this was
extremely important that was the year
when the protease inhibitors were become
popular and that really decreased the
viral load with between two and three
lakh so much deeper than with the model
therapy or double nucleotide
combinations and more importantly if you
would keep taking these these drugs then
there would be no resistance developing
and and that changed really everything
for the HIV patients because well life
went on you have to imagine that many of
the people who received in an AIDS or an
HIV diagnosis it was sort of a death
sentence and they took out their life
insurance made a trip around the world
and then came home to die and suddenly
you have these medications that
basically we'll be able to guarantee
these people a normal lifespan so that
changed everything dramatically for the
good because life goes on with these
with these heart therapy however it's
not all that great because um well at
that point in time taking HIV drugs
meant literally a handful of pills that
have to be taken during a day including
antibiotics including multiple doses of
different three antiviral drugs at the
same time people have to set their alarm
clock every six hours to wake up at
night or in the morning to take their
next dose and so therapy while following
exactly the therapy was with very
difficult for many of them but they knew
full well that if they would take a drug
holiday then well then the effect of the
therapy would would be eliminated man
the therapy still have a lot of side
effects at that time so although since
then HIV is not a at least in Western
countries where people can afford to be
awesome
expensive medications at that point in
time it was not a deadly disease anymore
it became a chronic disease
it was not a it was not a fiesta you
still had to take
a lot of a lot of medications this has
changed now - the only thing you have to
take now is one pill a day pain or for
fear
come together with with two other
antiviral medications in in this case
here in a triple a' guarantee you that
if you take one of these pills that then
well then that's all you have to take in
terms of antiviral medication any
declared from our institute was really
the father of tenofovir and he received
the volumes in award for biomedical
research together with anthony Falchi
and many of the if not most of the HIV
patients around the world receive
received these drugs that that contain
turn off of it 2004 was the year of the
tsunami in the india in the indian ocean
killing more than 200,000 people
beginning of facebook was also the
discovery or the uncovering of the
systematic torture in the Abu Ghraib
prison in Iraq and Armstrong wins his
sixth consecutive Tour de France but had
to hand them in again in 2012 because he
cheated this was the year when good news
for HIV started to come out this graph
illustrates the successful
antiretroviral therapy scale-up in
Malawi one of the hardest-hit countries
in terms of HIV and AIDS in Africa but
starting them and that program started
the the eight that started going down so
it was possible even in in less
privileged circumstances to to combat
HIV successfully with antiretroviral
drugs reducing mortality reducing
morbidity and very importantly reducing
also transmission of of the disease that
was also the year when the even more
automated platform the abbott architect
different models were were launched for
automatic machines where you can do a
lot of surgical testing including the
the HIV essays and that was the year
when the
first HIV antigen antibody combo so the
fourth-generation architect HIV si was
was launched with a a superior
sensitivity compared to the to the
earlier assays and then we immediately
go to 2014 the year of the Gaza war for
more than two thousand Palestinians
including five hundred children were
killed the year of Ebola in West Africa
with more than 11,000 people getting
killed the year that Germany wins the
World Cup soccer in Brazil and the first
time that a spaceship or the space probe
fill eye on the Rosetta project lands on
comet 67p this was the year last year
that UNH launched a very ambitious
project in order to try to get 90% of
all people living with HIV knowing their
HIV status that 90% of all people living
with HIV will receive and continue to
receive antiretroviral therapy and this
would be the year 2020 that 90% of all
people receiving antiretroviral therapy
will have a durable viral suppression so
that would be the lofty goal of w-h-o
and un8 for 2020 where we're not there
yet this is where we are in 2014 2015
about 37 million people are living with
with HIV but only 20 million are
diagnosed so 53 percent or diagnosed
small half of them are not diagnosed yet
about 41 percent are on antiretroviral
therapy and this is already much more
than a couple of years before that and
from these 15 million close to or 11.6
million people have viral suppression
with with extremely low viral loads and
that comes 2015 and you know that this
was not the best year this was the year
of juice we share each of the
attack on Charlie Hebdo in Paris
followed by the November terrorist
attacks in Paris this was the year of
the Volkswagen emissions scandal the
European migrant crisis but there was
also good news NASA announced the
present of flowing liquid water on on
Mars and UNH
this year proclaimed an even loftier
goal now the goal is not only to achieve
these 19 1990 goals by 2020 but this was
the first year that it was really
formulated that the the AIDS epidemic
should be ended by 2030 mathematical
projections show that if everybody does
is at most that it is really possible to
end the AIDS epidemic by 2030 so that
would mean that in a span of about 50
years a disease which caused a major
epidemic or pandemic would be would be
completely ended
we're only 2015 so we're still 15 years
away so that allows us still to be
optimistic in reaching in reaching that
goal I thank you for your attention
well thank you so much for that highly
informative presentation professor Rand
Rand we want to get right away to your
questions and input so here's a reminder
how to let us know what you have to say
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left we will try to
get to all of you but if not we will be
sure to follow up after the broadcast we
have lots of great questions coming in
and our first question is from Julia who
asks what is the most significant steps
for AIDS research uh and I assume that
Julia means which are the the next big
steps that needs to be that need to be
reached I think the the UNH goals of
1990 90s and the end of the epidemic by
2030 are the most important steps that I
know that's not a that's not a three
search that it's that it's policy or HIV
policy but we have all the necessary
tools to combat
there's this epidemic the only thing
which we cannot do yet is cure people
completely and this might be the the
ultimate goal the Holy Grail in
retrovirology or in HIV or AIDS research
is can we get a complete cure can we
eliminate desires from from the body and
that's still I think far far away okay
thank you next Georgio's tea from Oxford
University Hospital NIH Trust Act have
there been any recent evidence to
support the hypothesis that cross
regulation of co-stimulatory molecules
in cdat and CD 86 and ctla-4 can form
the basis of new t-cell mediated
therapies for HIV let's put that as one
of the as one of the lofty goals in HIV
research if that would be possible that
would that would mean that you're very
close to that means you're very close to
a pure I know that many people work on
this however for a disease which at its
worst cost five percent mortality or
five percent of the people on this
planet died of HIV and AIDS the the
resources devoted to these therapies are
actually not that great if you would put
all the HIV research researchers that
work on HIV pure and on HIV vaccines in
auditorium you actually would not feel a
complete auditorium with the principal
investigator so for a disease which
kills five percent of the human
population the resources that are are
given to this kind of resource or not
that great okay thank you next we have
Heather Jackson from Rogers State
University who says I see that there is
also a note of CMV infection were these
patients actively ill with
cytomegalovirus as well as Jessie or
Peter indeed the CMV play a role in the
disease progression or
or was it just chance well here
infections are always present or always
on our mind in people who are
immunosuppressed for whatever reason and
viola gist know that very well because a
lot of their time is devoted to
transplant patients with CMV problems so
CMV is one of these opportunistic
infections that are going to profit from
an immune system not functioning optimal
and it does the same in HIV so HIV for
example I'm sorry CMV
for example retinitis was one of the
before seedorf over here was discovered
was one of the major opportunistic
infections in HIV patients causing
blindness we don't see that anymore
because we know how to combat it
especially the CMV retinitis so CMV is
always a a nasty virus that we look out
for in immunocompromised patients of of
every kind the HIV or B transplant
patients great next we have Yousef from
the international project for laboratory
who asked who asks is there any strong
relationship between tuberculosis and
HIV AIDS and then he also asked what is
the different impact to HIV from MPR TB
and xdr-tb when you look at the when you
look at the map of countries suffering
greatly from HIV and you look at the map
of countries suffering greatly from
tuberculosis you will see that there is
a lot of overlapping so TB is definitely
one of these diseases that that again
profit from from people having HIV to
create a lot more a lot more havoc than
then it does alone although tuberculosis
this perfectly fine without HIV in terms
of killing people
together with HIV and malaria it belongs
to the three organisms that are the
major killers if you look at who kills
people or what kills people on this
planet you have HIV tuberculosis and
malaria so one bacteria one parasite and
one virus these three organisms kill
close to ten percent of the population
so yes they they will work synergetic
Lee in order to make people sick but
they can do quite nasty things on their
own
- great next we have Patrick s from
Florida Hospital Winter Park who asked
many infected individuals on medications
have an undetectable viral load if the
medications prevent replication and the
viral load is undetectable why doesn't
the immune system eradicate the virus
that's it that's a very important
question and there is a question with
HIV patients themselves very often ask
we luckily now we're in a situation
where many of the HIV patients come to
the lab and they receive or to their
physician and they receive the results
undetectable
six months later undetectable six months
later undetectable but undetectable does
not mean that the virus is not there and
they often think so and all of them at
certain point at a certain point in time
or are willing to sort of try to stop
the medication to see if they're not
secretly cured however every time that
they do this this I reload goes up again
and if they wait long enough with their
medication the viral load goes up again
till the point where they started and
and and in fact the progression will
will start again towards AIDS so there
is no there is no cure yet
the reason why the immune system cannot
completely combat it is because there
are HIV reservoirs in places in the body
where the immune system cannot really
reach it to wedley so there are some
hidden reservoirs or semi hidden weather
where the immune system cannot really do
its its complete task of eradicating
this virus we know that the cosmos iral
particles are or that our immune system
is perfectly capable to to handle a
couple of viral particles and eradicate
it completely but we're not reaching
that because of these reservoirs okay of
course the difference is dramatically in
African countries although that
situation has improved and has improved
by by a large margin over the last
couple of years
HIV is still I would say problem number
one really problem number one in Africa
wherever you go sub-sahara Africa HIV is
a disease which affects all people
either you are infected by HIV or you
are affected by HIV people die from HIV
or people take care of the children of
parents who died from HIV so HIV is
something which is for many people
regretfully a daily reality so it is
something which we tend not even start
to imagine in in Europe and the u.s. in
the u.s. at its peak about 1% of the
population with HIV infected in
countries such as Belgium it's closer to
0.1% so if you want to make it really
simple 0.1% in a an average European
country 1% in the US and 10% in an
average and I don't know that that
exists African country so the scale by
which HIV is a problem is is definitely
different around the world with a big
problem being that the less privileged
countries are the worst affected
we have another question from Heather J
from Rogers State University who asks if
the one pill does it combine all three
medications listed or there are three
medications still required a separate
medication no big progress has been made
over the past years to really make a
single pill that has to be taken daily I
know many of these people still take
other medications to combat or to
present opportunistic infections but
their antiretroviral drugs that really
literally used to be a handful of pills
every day has now gone down to one pill
one pill a day and that sort of
generated a a false sense of security
where a once deadly disease became a a
chronic disease which could be solved
with one pill and that in in some
countries and some parts of the
population that generated a false sense
of security as if HIV was not as
important as as it was in the past
great next Alexandre em from glorious
Memorial Institute course Memorial
Institute for Health Study asks what are
the chances to have an effective vaccine
in the next years many people are asking
the same question and I see this
question coming up in the lists of
questions a couple of times in the
beginning people said or in five to ten
years we'll have a vaccine I'm an
optimistic person and I would still say
the same however we've seen a lot of
well failures of the HIV vaccines that
were in clinical trials the problem is
that a it's not simple you're actually
shooting at a moving target you're
actually shooting at a moving target
that is move incredibly fast HIV is one
of the most rapidly mutating RNA viruses
so it's definitely
not easy to make a vaccine against
against these kinds of viruses but the
economic realities also saw that many of
these pharmaceutical companies are
currently making these empty barrel
virus we know that anti retrovirals or
with anti retrovirals you can eradicate
HIV which means and personally I don't
think that that's the right course but
then hey I'm not one of these these
companies leaders that the the resources
devoted to finding novel HIV vaccines
probably is not at a level where it it
should be and I think people are
becoming more and more complacent by
thinking that with antiretroviral drugs
we'll be able to eradicate HIV in theory
it is possible it is even perfectly
possible because HIV is not all that
easily transmitted you need sex in most
cases you need sex to transmit the
infection and God knows about all that
easy so you could not avoid getting the
flu but you can avoid getting HIV so
combined with treating the already
existing patients in theory and ematic
medical models it is possible to
eradicate HIV using anti retrovirals
alone however as action would have been
a much preferred solution but hey we
don't have it and well it's hard to
predict the future because the future
doesn't didn't happen yet that's
actually Yogi Berra the New York Yankees
catcher who once said that so it's well
we don't know I mean we can keep hoping
for an HIV vaccine but as the years are
progressing and as we might near 2030
and as it goes in the right direction
with HIV eradication maybe we won't get
it and maybe we don't need it I like
your optimism next we have do penang
from the cdc who asks can you comment on
HIV vaccine Rd and what role of cd4 and
viral viral load should
in treatment monitoring well I think we
already covered some of the HIV vaccine
R&D although I think that much larger
researchers resources should be devoted
to it viral load monitoring HD is the
mainstay treatment monitoring that we
have right now in the beginning we were
quite reluctant to use high remote
monitoring very often because it was is
quite expensive compared to cd4
monitoring when the ears are progressing
I think most of the most of the
physicians really rely on viral load
treatment monitoring quite regularly and
frankly at every visit that the the HIV
patient bring to the hospital most of
the time a viral load measurement will
be will be taken luckily in many times
it will be undetectable
and if it's not then a change in therapy
can be can be done so viral load
monitoring and genotypic resistance
monitoring are at this moment the most
important may be replacing cd4
monitoring although if I look at my lab
very often when they ask if I reload I
see that the cd4 is still asked for from
Johns Hopkins University who asked he
could comment on the rising prevalence
of AIDS in Asia Asia was one of the was
what was was the lost continent where
HIV would rise so in a certain point in
time people thought okay maybe Asia will
escape the the AIDS epidemic however
that's not the case
Asia and the Pacific region is now
confronted with a devastating hiv/aids
epidemic but instead of the the 1980s it
only started in the even late 1990s to
be really established around the around
the
we each and we can also see that and
that's the same in Africa as in Asia
that although the the epidemic started
later there we also see the same decline
in death and that can be written on the
account of antiretroviral therapy in
Asia too
so about 25% decline or 30% decline in
Africa close to 30 35 % declining that
in in Asia since successful X therapy
was launched we have 12 from file spider
technologies who asked under optimal
anti HIV therapy how many patients if
any can achieve non-detectable HIV virus
status I think most can can reach
non-detectable HIV virus status if if a
patient is compliant so which means if
the patient takes his or her medication
on time
the way it should be taken then many if
not most will reach HIV non-detectable
virus status so if if that's not the
case then very often the D HIV therapy
is not HIV therapy is not optimal and
then you have to look at HIV resistant
developing or change the the HIV
treatment regimen to achieve
non-detectable HIV status it's actually
when we do viral loads now in in
patients that are on therapy for a long
time most of the results are are
undetectable or close to undetectable we
have lots of great questions coming in
but unfortunately we have only time for
one more question
so the final question is from Baqir are
from Mayo Clinic who asks sorry I lost
my spot for one minute
who asks if it's the same treatment
medical treatment for HIV 1 and HIV 2
effective for both yeah that's a great
question
first of all most of the research has
been done on and I think rightfully so
because that was the biggest problem on
HIV 1 and we know that HIV to the Nutri
treatment is less than in HIV 1 so many
people and especially in the beginning
years when the treatment modalities had
a lot of side effects
we chose not to receive therapy and
since the disease were slowly
progressing it it would work some of the
anti retrovirals work in HIV 2 but this
is definitely under studied and
remarkably under studied in fact well I
would like to convince again to thank
professor gran-gran's for his
presentation um do you have any final
precincts or final comment for us no I
would like to thank everybody for
attending and spending some time on the
on the history of HIV and it's it's a
storm it's a sad story of course but
it's also a story where we can get a lot
of hope if we as as humanity can be
confronted with a disease and solve it
in a matter of a couple of decades I
think that's that's not a small feat
that is something to be optimistic about
well once again thank you for your
presentation if we weren't able to speak
directly with you today we'll be sure to
follow up with you thank you for taking
part we want to thank today's presenter
as well for joining us here at lab roots
the leading scientific social networking
site for more information please visit
us at lab roots com today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing and
on our web site through May 2016 we will
let you know when it's been posted and
we hope you pass that information on to
any colleagues who couldn't take part in
today's webcast see you next time and
good bye